don't worry i checked throughout  scenario  agent falls in love is gone agent runs  amok bill gets kidnapped the other guys  want to know the agent source what does  he do will they do to the girl  how do you get this ebay dude this is  super illegal right this no no Wow  putting the lights on kinda is then I  went to Kinko's it goes Oh plaster it on  myself this is crazy dude book last  minute to do is Trina shows in Seattle  we gotta leave tonight so how long I  don't know like a week 10 days it's hard  to say never with plans remember for my  birthday dinner all in quietly if Master  Splinter catches us hell send us back to  the Hashi ain't going back to hush